hi this is a
Sadashiva from science mission today we
have a dr. Gertz mission by a
distinguished professor from the
Department of bioengineering at the
University of California San Diego is
with us dr. Smith Sean Bain is a member
of National Academy of Engineering and
is a fellow of American Heart
Association he is a founding fellow of
the American Institute for medical and
biomedical engineering biological
engineering and winner of the Melville
medal from the American Society for
mechanical engineering he won the gold
medal by the International Society of
biology and Eugene M Landis award by the
micro circulatory Society in addition he
has published several peer-reviewed
journal articles and he has several
grants to his credit and he's in the
editorial board of some journals welcome
dr. Smith Sean Bain welcome thank you
for having me
let's get going now so can you please
talk about yourself your background and
some of the things we are doing in the
lab right I my background this actually
I was a physics student a physics and I
studied physics at the time when ba
engineering was not academic credit
course but I was very fortunate to be
able to get into one of the earliest by
engineering programs in San Diego and as
a physics major became very interested
in this topic area of the physics of
living cells and living and that is in a
nutshell my it's in life okay and can
you talk about your like how did you
progress in your career and how you
reached where you are right now and
that's a very
Christene question which in fact in my
presentation will become more apparent
to you okay I big I basically became
interested in the question is it
possible for an engineer or physicist to
develop new ideas about the origin of
human disease what how I started out I
started by studying small blood vessels
blood flow in small blood vessels cell
properties molecular properties
biological molecular properties and
eventually I found out that these are
all interesting basic science problem
but the real important issue is to ask
can you apply them to something that's
important for society and that's human
disease and so today I'm a physicist
who's a bioengineer who thinks entirely
about the origin of human disease okay
that's interesting and let's talk about
your lab your lab people can you leave
the most important part in once in my
life of course had great fortune of
being able to work for many years with a
large number of students and accredit
all the way from freshmen to seniors
many of the students then stayed on and
received an advanced degree with me and
not only do we have students from bio
engineering but we also have students
from other medical disciplines which is
very important very inspiring so I'm
gonna show you a slide with some of the
students that have worked together with
me just for the project I'm going to
tell you about okay anymore there many
more so life in in in in the laboratory
laboratory basically is a very boring
environment but it's very exciting when
you have exciting conversations with
students and they are enthusiastic about
the problems they are working on okay so
as you brought that up regarding lab is
boring what else other than lab thinks
you and your fellow the most important
part is the laboratory
okay for many people I know but when I'm
not in the laboratory obviously family
is very important but if you ask me
specifically for hobbies first of all I
like to go hiking we have wonderful
places where you can go hiking here and
where I live you go and one of the
hobbies I have is to grow things I'm
trying to find out is it possible in our
climate to grow a banana tree okay okay
that's nice nice to know coming back to
the research so you have recently I've
been working on auto digestion and all
those things can you give us a little
bit preview of how come you got
interested in that and then you can go
on present your work yes that that I'm
delighted to speak about this is
literally my work and my life's work
I'll give you a reason why I why we are
working on this now but I won't have
time to speak about the history of that
and to summarize the history in a
nutshell we made over the years many
many mistakes many mistakes until we
finally started to get a focus on human
disease that I feel the first time I'm
more confident in as compared to many
other discussions in the past and I hope
to tell you why I feel that way I hope
your audience is very skeptical of what
I'm going to say and I love to hear from
the audience
anybody has an objection or thinks this
is all not correct
I'd learn from them directly and hear
skeptical questions but to answer your
question in my mind as bioengineer to
work on human disease is one of the most
important things we need to do and here
is an opportunity to think about human
disease in a fashion that
is non-conventional and most important
of course is the question can you open
up new opportunities on how to treat
disease and most important how to
prevent it how to how to tell your
fellow citizen what leads to a
particular disease so this is something
that I'm trying to inspire students and
the particular angle that we will take
or the digestion has come out of many
years of as I said making mistakes so if
you can present your work that'll be
great be delighted to do that
yeah I can see that right wonderful so
you read in this title two things the
top line says digestive enzymes so I
will be spending a lot of time thinking
about that speaking about digestive
enzymes okay below is or the digestion
that's a phenomenon and I will explain
what this means but in today's talk I
will apply to some diseases to shock and
to death these are important problems in
medicine and I need to start out by
saying that all this work has been over
many years supported by the National
Institute of Health by the American
Heart Association and recently also by a
private company become apparent why that
is the case and I have to tell the
audience that I have a conflict of
interest because I own some stocks in
this particular private company leaving
bioscience ok now the most important
slide I really need to say here already
what we discussed earlier is there is
what I'm going to tell you is derived
from the effort of an entire team of
people on the left side I have listed
students undergrad students graduate
students and post doctoral fellows who
worked with me over the last especially
20 years on this particular project
right side there is a list of
collaborators with whom we work they are
clinicians their basic scientists and so
you can think of this idea of auto
digestion really being something that
has evolved it wasn't just a single
quick idea from a person in the
laboratory but it's something that
evolved about many years in many decades
for that matter so a best way to explain
why we do and why we focus on the
problem that we do is to think about
this process that many people in the
public know now
it's called inflammation it's an old
word was introduced by some pathologists
about 1822 and it the remarkable thing
in the last twenty years or maybe close
to 25 years is that just about every
human disease has now been identified to
be an inflammatory disease we read on
the newspapers about that and I often
ask myself what does this really mean
those who did Studies on tissues say
cultures or animal studies have known
all along that there is inflammation but
it was remarkable development that
clinicians so clinical trials were able
to show that the patient's they were in
the interested and investigating had
signs of inflammation
now you can roughly divide this a little
simplified I recognize that you can
divide the inflammatory diseases into
two general classes one is what's listed
here on top what people call infectious
inflammation these are states of
inflammation patients in which indeed
you are able to demonstrate that
bacterial viral fungal and other
microorganisms may be around and in fact
there are treatments that medicine has
for these particular conditions there's
also another very large class of inflam
inflammatory conditions that are I call
them non-infectious these include for
example something like acute injuries
this is an injury that happens a very
short period of time there's not enough
time to grow a bacterial culture
cardiovascular diseases metabolic
syndrome
that is a state of elevated diabetes
arterial hypertension and so on
atherosclerosis has been repeatedly
proposed that atherosclerosis is an
infectious disease but the evidence he
never became really conclusive and
certainly we don't have any treatment
for arthrosclerosis today that's derived
from a anti-infectious approach and this
list goes on and on there's cancer many
cancers fall into this certainly aging
and today I'm gonna highlight especially
a situation that's called sepsis and
physiological shock and then multi organ
failure that's sort of a sequence of
events that eventually leads to death
and therefore if you're looking for an
important human disease or condition
looking at sepsis is a very good way and
it turns out as you'll see in a second
this was an important entry point so
when a clinician identifies a
inflammatory stage typically in today's
diagnostic portfolio a venous blood
sample has been collected and then
inflammatory mediators sexy reactive
protein or the interleukin 6 many others
are being measured and if you have in
your bloodstream elevated levels of
these particular proteins then in that
particular case you will be classified
as being in an inflamed inflame state
now when I look at this inflammatory
event I asked myself if every human
disease has these inflammatory mediators
what is nature telling us well we have
to go back to the basic idea of
inflammation it is actually a repair
mechanism that Nature has introduced and
its unique to living organisms and this
repair mechanisms is very nicely studied
for example if you generates a skin
scratch and
you then look at the response of this
tissue and that leads into what people
call an inflammatory cascade that's
probably a better term and its whole
purpose is to repair so typical states
in there are there is right after the
injury and enhanced response in the
tissue in terms of elevated permeability
there is i'm exchange there's a variety
of other reactions that occur in the
tissue many of these we know in great
detail today
these local responses to the injury are
followed by a removal of the old tissue
the debris has to be removed we don't
have many capabilities of repairing has
to say a mechanically injured tissue it
really needs to be completely replaced
and therefore we have cells like
neutrophils and monocytes and lymphocyte
infiltration that actually carry out
this task there was a tremendous amount
of work today aspects of this understood
that process is then once the debris has
been removed is replaced by a neo
Genesis both blood vessels as well as
tissue is newly generated and that for
example mediated in part by macrophages
that start to release growth factors and
these growth factors in turn lead to a
growth of blood vessels and connective
tissue and eventually end up with what
traditionally has been called the
resolution of inflammation namely it is
a repair you may have a scar tissue but
in the end you have you can live with it
so this tissue repair is actually
absolutely vital in in in life we need
this not only when we injure ourselves
we needed a childbirth and for many many
other physiological processes so if you
think of inflammation which is present
in all of these patients you ask
yourself the question if this is a
repair mechanism what has caused the
injury in the first place if this tissue
needs to repair
something has injured the tissue so as
an engineer I ask myself a lot the
question what could possibly engine
tissues and I wrote to here a list of
general classes of injury that can occur
besides the infection you can for
example injure your lung by inhaling
nanoparticles you may be subject to some
trauma they of course all kinds of
traumas may be a rupture of a tissue
puncture etc you may expose yourself to
elevated temperatures you may have a
chemical exposure you may be exposed to
radiation so there's a long list of
possible mechanisms by which our tissue
can be injured the question is is this
list complete and what I will advocate
today is is no it's not and the best way
I can explain this to you by
illustrating to you a case a very
specific case that for many years played
an important role in our work to
identify mechanisms for inflammation and
for the auto digestion this is very
simple experiment all you need to do is
to place a catheter into the femoral
artery there's nothing else in the local
anesthesia you put it in the animal
Sonesta size and now you reduce the
blood pressure this is shown here as a
mean arterial blood pressure from its
typical value somewhere between 100 and
110 millimeter mercury you drop it down
by bleeding the animal so with that
catheter so now you lower the blood
pressure to a value that you wish to
have it's calls let's say 40 millimeter
mercury you hold this blood pressure for
a certain period of time and at the end
this is in this participate two hours
you then return also the blood back to
the animal so this is the blood
withdrawn at the beginning and then we
return it efforts so this is an animal
that has been subject to just a very
simple process namely a loss of blood
for a certain period of time a injury on
the road when somebody's artery is being
cut would be the counterpart of what
happens in in in in the clinic and this
is called hemorrhagic shock at the end
of this period you find two types of
animal behaviors one is a group of
animal that will just die within two or
three hours they are dead and then
there's another group that will survive
and we were always curious about this is
why would we get two different responses
from these animals even though we
applied the same insult in terms of the
blood withdraw so we spend a lot of time
to try to understand what is the
difference between these survivors and
these non survivors and one of the
experiments you can do that was
instructive is to take a blood sample at
the end just a tiny sample and you apply
it to some naive cells we happen to
select circulating blood cells
leukocytes that were from a donor so
circulating leukocytes when you look at
them with the scanning electron
microscope are nice and round cells have
the surface fold here's another example
and when you take the plasma from the
animals that survived they all look like
this in contrast if you look at the
animals that do not survive and take
their plasma you start to see that a lot
of these cells are in an activated State
this is an activation we understand a
lot of details about that by which these
cells starts to project pseudopods so
that's a nice simple experiment that
graduate students and undergraduate
students can do and now ask the
important question what is the
difference between the plasma applied to
these cells versus the plasma of the non
survivors of that generate this type of
behavior so there is something in the
plasma of these
early on fairly early on just one or two
hours after the beginning of the under
perfusion of the animal that leads to
this particular behavior and these by
the way have a lot of consequences for
the circulation they impair the
circulation and there's no surprise that
these animals with these type of cells
have problems and this is just one
indicator there are many other cells you
could study where we would also find out
that the plasma derived from these
nonsurvivors
generates all kinds of properties so I
mentioned at the beginning we made lots
of mistakes well for many years we were
searching for what could possibly cause
this type of response that you see at
the bottom and our thinking was well
there probably is some chemical in the
plasma some mediator that will stimulate
this type of response and we spent many
years many decades to look for possible
candidates and to make a long story
short it all failed there was there were
lots of mediators present for example a
compliment we explored for a number of
years yes indeed we find activated
complement but when we did a test an
important test namely try to remove
compliment from the plasma of these
animals we did not eliminate this type
of behavior so it was clear that
multiple mediators are present but we
were unable to remove these mediators
and by the way we were not the only ones
interested in this question there were
many other groups find all kinds of
mediators but nobody was able to show
now that the particular mediator that I
had identified could be lipids could be
proteins peptides was actually
responsible for this type of stimulation
of naive cells so for many years I was
unhappy because I felt unless we are
able to understand how this process
comes about we're not able to make a
difference in the survival of this type
of animal
and therefore anybody in shock or sepsis
we would not be able to help the break
so happened when a graduate student Erik
Kistler one day came to me in in the
office and said why don't we look at the
different organs of an animal that has
been subjected to shock and I said to
Erik
yes it's an interesting thing but likely
you're just gonna find out that every
organ could be a potential mediator of
these type of inflammatory reactions and
I encouraged him to do that experiment
he took out the different organs that
you see listed here and he in cube aided
them for about two hours just on the
bench for at 37 degrees just like if it
were a reaction in the tissue then took
the supernatant of these organ reactions
and asked the question which one will
activate the cells just like you saw on
the previous slide and out of this
experiment came something really
surprising it was predominantly the
pancreas that was a surprise I said well
the others have a little bit of that but
the pancreas is really all by itself I
then asked him why don't you take an
important protein that synthesized in
the pancreas trypsin I'll explain a
little bit more about that and add this
to all the other homogeneous to it and
longer behold he saw that in fact
trypsin was stimulating all of these
cell projections just like we saw it for
the pancreas in fact if you add trypsin
to the pancreas you don't change very
much interesting in the intestine if you
flush the intestine which is this blue
bar here then in that particular case
you get very low levels of ACTA site
activation but if you add trypsin back
into it then you get the red bar and you
get an elevation that's similar to what
you
seeing other organs so this experiment
this little in vitro experiment told us
that there is something about digestive
enzymes and therefore the whole focus of
our study suddenly shifted and I had to
think about these organs so let me take
you briefly through it this is the
stomach here is the upper part of the
small intestine that's this long organ
that's all wound up in our abdomen and
here right below the stomach is the
pancreas that pancreas discharges its
contents through the duodenum and
therefore when food comes into the small
intestine right below what's called the
pylorus valve the digestive enzymes and
the food that we just consumed will mix
and then go on this right through the
small intestine eventually in ends up in
the large intestine which is really just
one loop
but the digestion of the food will occur
in this small intestine almost
exclusively so what's happening in the
pancreas well the pancreas does
basically two things in life one is and
that's a very small part of the
intestine only about 5% produces the
insulin the islet cells 95% of the
pancreas is a busy organ generating the
digestive enzymes and digestive enzymes
of course absolutely vital otherwise we
could not eat and we could not use the
nutrients of what we eat they consists
of four classes of enzymes one are
protolithic enzyme so they contain
enzymes like trypsin chymotrypsin
elastase and a few others it contains
lipases these are lipids degrading
enzymes amylase which can break down
sugars and finally a nucleases which can
break down RNA and DNA so these enzymes
are absolutely vital for life because
they are responsible to make sure that
when we eat a plate that
within a period of less than 24 hours
this wonderful plate will look like
which I will not describe any further on
this public announcement we are compared
with this so we have a machinery in our
intestine that we use every day to break
down the food that we do large amounts
of biomolecules as part of our nutrition
this is the digestion part we take it
for granted we never know that it
actually happens I show you this
particular plate because it shows some
sausages and the skin of these suckers
is actually made of intestine in men in
most manufacturing of intestines and you
are therefore justified to ask a very
important question it's more than just a
dinner talk what mechanisms do I have to
prevent myself digesting my own
intestine what prevents all the
digestion that is suddenly a very
important question to ask
very few people ask that question well
what may prevent the Jessen of my
intestine and my intestinal wall is
likely a barrier it's a protection
mechanism that's provided by the barrier
and in this electron microscopic section
that you see here this is a
cross-section through an intestine of a
cat and you see the various layers of
the intestine there is the layer with
these villi it increases the surface
area of the intestine in the lumen
itself is the food together with these
digestive enzymes I just showed you this
layer is called the mucosal layer is
surrounded by a muscle to muscle layers
that provide the peristaltic motion so
that a food bolus can be carried along
the length of the intestine after meal
so the question that arises is is what
protection mechanism is in that wall
well
you have to magnify it a little bit
further and what I'm showing you here is
now one of these villi magnified and it
is layer this here in this particular
picture especially clearly visible here
is the muscle layer that you just shot
this is in a cap this one is a raptor
looks slightly different but the basic
mechanism by which they produce and
absorb and transport food is similar in
the two species these projections are
the villi and they themselves consists
of many epithelial cells so this is a
layer of epithelial cells that covers
the entire intestine
now these epithelial cells have to be
protected against your own digestive
enzymes and the way this is achieved is
that there is a slight slimy layer a
mutant layer that covers these
epithelial cells and these villi and
there are two types actually there is a
recent two isoform and there's amusing
13 isoform the one that 13 actually sits
on the epithelial cell on the what's
called the brush border whereas the
mutant 2 is actually fluffed off from a
cells called the goblet cell and it's
being carried away in the intestine
together with the food so when you go
potty what you will see is musing - and
the mutant 13 has to stay behind on top
of the epithelial cell now the question
is okay if this barrier is responsible
for protection against all the digestion
how good is this barrier we know
barriers are not perfect and when we
study that here's an example of this we
find out that it actually can leak so I
show this to you in these images they're
called thymic Rafi let me orient you
this is the muscle layer here at the
bottom appears the food and here the
villi barely visible the billa what
we've done here is is we put a little
peptide
on top of this tissue section and this
peptide has the feature that is
essentially non fluorescent but when it
is being clipped by a digestive enzyme
in this particular case we targeted
trypsin it becomes fluorescent so in a
sham situation you see in a normal
control there is a little bit of
fluorescence interesting enough also on
the abdominal side but it's relatively
low on the other hand if we introduce
what's called Sao a splenic artery
occlusion which is nothing else but an
and the profusion of the intestine in
that particular case we start to see
this bright blue if you do it for 30
minutes in fact the entire wall of the
intestine becomes fluorescent telling us
that now the digestive enzyme of instead
of being in the lumen of the intestine
they have actually entered into the wall
of the intestine that is a short period
of time a full entry of digestive
enzymes and escape out of the intestine
now the Goom asked the question is this
an important event well this is a bright
field image of the same intestine
stained with an H and E stain and you
can see this is the normal realized
structure after 15 minutes the tip of
the villi has already been digested
their way and after 30 minutes
in fact the length of the villi is now
reduced because the top part has been
completely digested so this is Auto
digestion and this is a terrible event
oh my god when these digestive enzymes
escape they do all kinds of terrible
things I have nothing else but bad news
[Music]
it's better yeah can you hear me
yeah no it's usually very loose the
black bars is the protease is this my
part yeah yeah good now let's see okay I
hear you very clearly can you hear me
yeah yeah in-between it was kind of like
blurry yeah again it is blaring hello oh
yeah is the microphone anything okay
right
so she finds plasma proteins in these
different class my proteins no it is
breaking up should we re-establish a
line because I don't know what you could
touch here on my computer okay no it
comes out now okay but when you start
going it is kind of like breaking up
better now yeah it is better now just
you have to tell me where you is it
better now yeah I'll go ahead now it's
breaking up
ah okay hello I can't hear you properly
your back is that would that be okay
just mute and unmute your this thing
once just to make sure that it works
[Music]
no it is just kind of fun okay I don't
hear you just talk something like so
that I can make sure that you can hear
me polite right now you are just totally
breaking up okay
tonight Google no you you you if if you
create what happens is it will go away
everything will go away because it's
recording no let me see
[Music]
one two three one two three okay it is
fine now one two three okay yeah I can
you know it's it better yeah yeah we had
some rain here in San Diego so but it
just stopped
okay now I can hear it is fine now okay
so can you edit this then later on no I
can't do anything I have no option which
is okay it's about 20 or 30 seconds
that's okay okay so both the plasma and
the peritoneal cavity are filling with
digestive enzymes after high hemorrhagic
shock and these enzymes are actually
active they are not just present as a
protein but these are active proteases
there is a second effect that takes
place the digestive enzymes will
activate other Pro MMPs and other Pro
enzymes and this is an example for mmp9
both the molecule itself is not present
before shock but it Pierce after shock
and this is shown here by as imma gram
and by a Western blot and these are the
measurements associated with that we
also find that digestive enzymes besides
being in the plasma are also present in
the lung in the liver and in the heart
and even in the brain this all within a
period of about two hours after
hemorrhagic shock so this evidence tells
us that digestive enzymes are escaping
from the lumen of the intestine in
hemorrhagic shock and they escape into
just about every organ in the body now
the question is arises yeah maybe
they're not doing very much well I can
give you one example that in illustrates
in a very dramatic way that this entry
of digestive enzymes is a highly
destructive process and is illustrated
by this diagram
say mass spectral scan somewhere between
about 5000 kilo Dalton and about 15,000
killer Dalton and the peaks you see here
are typical biomolecules and that of
many of them are well understood to be
present in the plasma of a rat humans
look similar these molecules are vital
signs used for all kinds of vital
processes and this particular profile I
could show you many others they look
very similar is before the animal is in
shock so this is the profile that you
would see in a healthy animal if you
know from the same animal two hours
later after shock look at the same
spectrum it looks like the one here at
the bottom and the best I can describe
this is there is a wholesale destruction
of biomolecules in the plasma of these
animals and therefore no surprise that
these animals cannot survive we carried
out a more detailed study where we
looked at the peptides present these are
peptides between about 5 amino acids and
15 kilo Dalton and whereas a control
animal has about 126 such peptides in
after hemorrhagic shock this goes up
almost by a factor 2 up to 3 so these
animals are destroying their own
biomolecules due to the presence of
these digestive enzymes these
biomolecules come from many different
sources and we have been able to
identify several of them in fact they
are published one important question
that came up early in this work was ok
this shows an elusive inter stomach
intestine and
: if this process occurs in the small
intestine would there ever be a
possibility that we can interfere with
those digestive enzymes and the approach
we developed early on this was in 2000
is to say why don't we make local
injections into the small intestine it's
be introducing inhibitor for the
digestive enzymes we used it a drug that
was previously developed to inhibit
digestive enzymes in the case of
pancreatitis and we were able to show
when you do that you block in vite
digestive enzymes you block it go back
one more time in the small intestine
only we didn't touch the large intestine
neither will touch the stomach just over
this length we found out that if you do
that and you expose the animal to
hemorrhagic shock and you then wait for
an extended period of time whether the
animal will survive or not survive this
is a group of animals twelve animals
three only survived because they were
not treated in the animals that were
treated with this drug I mentioned ang D
and it was given entirely that means
just in the lumen of the intestine the
treatment group had 10 out of 12 we then
said well maybe this is some artifact
about this particular protease inhibitor
which is a synthetic molecule developed
by a Japanese company why don't we use
some other molecules we used another
protease inhibitor called tranexamic
acid and an older one that's been in the
literature for a while called a protein
they have very different chemical
structure and we repeated these
experiments by administering them into
the lumen of the intestine entirely and
we're able to show that you get a
significant increase in survival in all
of them as a matter of fact we were able
to show that in other forms of shock
other than a hemorrhagic shock you can
get a similar improvement
survival what does this look like in
real inside an animal well this is a
normally intestine of a rat this is the
right heart the atrium and here's the
lung
this is how it looks like in a control
animal this is how it looks like in an
animal that has been subjected to this
hemorrhagic shock the dark red
coloration you see is due to the fact
that red blood cells were escaping
across as mostly V notes in the
microcirculation
and they leak directly into the tissue
so you can't wash them out and this
leakage relegion sites develop in the
right heart of the Europe in the lung
every one of the animals look slightly
different but this is a consistent
finding when we block the digestive
enzymes in the lumen of the intestine so
we don't give any drug ivy we just plug
them right in here and this is after one
hour so in other words we were trying to
simulate a human situation where it
takes about an hour for the patient to
be delivered into the intensive care
unit then we start to see that there is
a significant improvement of these
lesion formations both in the heart as
well as in the lung
so this told us if we block these
digestive enzymes at the site where
they're very concentrated we can
potentially interfere with this what's
called multi organ failure that is the
consequence of the manifestation of
which we see in these particular images
in fact over the years we have done lots
of studies with this idea of blocking
digestive enzymes directly in the lumen
of intestine in indeed the animals
cannot digest during this period of time
and what here I want to show one other
example of how this works the animals
develop what's called an acute insulin
resistance let me explain so if you give
an animal that bonus of glucose you
start to see that it takes in these
cases about two hours for this glucose
in the blood to return back to control
value we can also do the experiment in
an inverted fashion you give insulin so
you see a drop in glucose levels and
gradually if we store
again this is how a control healthy rat
would respond if you now take an animal
that has been subject to hemorrhagic
shock these are the red points you start
to see that first of all there is
already an elevation of the glucose
levels even in the early stage and then
in fact the animal really never fully
recovers it blood glucose levels if you
give insulin you get still a response
and the reduction of blood glucose
levels but it is a sluggish response and
much reduced if you treat the animal
these are the blue points and with a
inhibition of digestive enzymes just
like I showed you previously you see
that this hypoglycemic or insulin
resistance state is in fact normalized
back to a control this experiment taught
us that the digestive enzyme to damage
to the insulin system and the way we
examine this is is by taking an antibody
against the extracellular domain of the
insulin receptor so here you see some
blood vessels in the microcirculation
arterioles bnotes and capillaries that
have been labeled with an antibody
against the extracellular domain of the
insulin receptor and this is how it
looks like on the end of yourself if you
do the same labeling identical optical
conditions of an animal that's in shock
hemorrhagic shock you see still some
labeling but if you compare this image
with that image I hope you can see that
on your screen you see a dramatic
reduction of the insulin receptor
density if you
if you pretreat the animal with
tranexamic acid in this particular case
this loss of the insulin receptor
labeling on the extrasolar domain what
present anymore
that's supported by direct fluorescent
measurements these are digital horizon
measurements both in the arterioles
capillaries and menials by the time we
treat we attenuate this loss of the
insulin receptor so the concept that
became apparent as far as the receptors
are concerned is that a normal intercept
it's a dimer very well understood today
and when insulin comes around and binds
to the extra cellular binding domain and
then signals internally towards what is
eventually a glucose transport through
simplest transporters into the cell
interior that process in shock is
interrupted and it's interrupted at the
very beginning namely proteases that are
coming from the extracellular
compartment digestive enzymes included
and they will clip the extra cell domain
of the insulin receptor so the signaling
mechanism is now interrupted and as a
consequence all signaling that this
downstream of the insulin receptor
transport chain is now interrupted and
you have an insulin resistance state
we're able to show this phenomenon in
variety of different receptors over the
years and therefore it is this loss of
cell function is an early stage of all
the digestion by the digestive enzymes
now in a very important question came up
early is okay if inhibition of digestive
enzymes in the intestine would help
could it ever make a difference in a
human being and it turns out that I was
witnessing a case a special case which I
want to show you briefly now how do we
introduce into humans
digestive enzymes well the only way we
can do that is this is we can't do it
like with
in the rats where we had to open up the
abdomen and we have to do it with a
catheter and what we do is is we place a
catheter directly into the most distal
part of the stomach it's difficult to go
any further
and then we drip in a protease inhibitor
and that produce inhibitor will slowly
make its way through the rest of the
intestine so this process took place in
a patient in in a heart transplant
center that had a heart transplant and
after it's a couple of years later had a
motorcycle accident and this individual
by the time we came in contact with was
in a classical state of shock and sepsis
the intestine when looked at with an
x-ray was totally distended and when you
looked at the biochemical parameters and
hemodynamic parameters of this patient
it was so that the patient would not
have survived even a few more days so
the clinicians at the time based on
consent by asking the loved ones
decided to place a catheter just like I
showed you they treated this patient
this was the first one to our knowledge
in the medical history in the medical
literature and they treated this and
this is the same individual and
intestine 16 days later this was at the
time it was transferred out of the ICU
into the hospital ward and this
individual about three or four months
later in fact went back home and is
still alive today well what what is
unusual about this case is this because
this person had a heart transplant he
was not only not quite so healthy as a
normal individual but on top of that he
was immune suppressed and he responded
to this so this idea is today in
clinical trial we are in the process of
enrolling a group of patient
that have such complications and we are
hoping that by the end of 2019 we will
have the first results whether this type
of treatment could potentially help and
by the way this is in order to do these
type of studies are very expensive you
need to have a company that does that
and that's what this company I mentioned
at the beginning leading bioscience is
actually doing at this point
now another independent piece of
evidence became a pair of ailable to us
just a few months ago in a consortium
study with several European trauma
centres we were able to get plasma from
septic patients these are very these
very sick patients in that and we were
able to get it over two days on the time
of the day they are delivered and the
day later and it's a small group only
about 23 patients but what we did with
this plasma we reasoned in the following
way we said well if digestive enzymes
are present just like we saw it in their
rat is there a possibility that these
the patient's own pepper proteins are
being broken down into individual
peptides so we did mass spectrometry we
counted peptides in a certain molecular
weight range and you see here a measure
of peptide abundance for the case of
septic patients these numbers are from
individuals that would all survive if
you look at individuals is always a
small proportion our case was 6 patients
that would not survive they already had
on time of delivery elevated levels of
these peptides but on the next day and
this is in many of these patients just
sometimes hours or just a few days away
from death we saw this dramatic increase
in
[Music]
peptides abundance telling us that these
patients just like in our rats we're
destroying their own digestive enzymes
we could get some bioinformatics
information about what proteases may be
involved in that but we don't know we
don't have independent measurements of
the actual proteases we suspect that
chymotrypsin is a major player and these
values are dramatically higher compared
to individuals like controls or healthy
individuals so this is a to us an
independent signal that when digestive
enzymes get into the bloodstream they
will actually destroy not only receptors
as I showed you but they also destroy
plasma proteins so in summary what I've
told you up to this point is that this
escape of digestive enzymes activates
secondary enzymes I've showed you an
example for the MNPs
it leads to an actual destruction of the
tissue we just call it all the digestion
is receptor cleavage many different
receptors are involved and eventually in
if the case is severe enough it leads to
multi organ failure and and death and if
you inhibit the digestive enzymes
through this internal administration you
can actually interfere with all of these
processes you don't interfere with the
escape of the digestive enzyme because
that's a breakdown of the barrier but
you can interfere with all of the
secondary reactions that take place and
so today the big question is could that
be used to save the life of patients in
the intensive care in the patients with
sepsis and so on the good news is the
clinical trials are underway and we have
to wait for the outcome of that so what
I told you so far is this digestive
enzymes can kill you if they are allowed
to escape you don't need to enrich them
you don't need to have a higher
expression of their values the ones you
have in your intestine is enough so if
the barrier breaks down it
Kilian given this fact I was curious for
many years well okay in shock there is
this dramatic breakdown of the barrier I
showed you but what about more milder
more milder circumstances and I had the
great fortune to being able with a group
of graduate students and postdocs to
study an animal which is known as the
spontaneously hypertensive friend I'm
gonna use the acronym s HR this animal
is celebrated today was generated it by
professor Okamoto at Kyoto University
for the fact that it's mean arterial
blood pressure of its lifetime this is a
twelve-months a record that you see here
it's significantly elevated compared to
an animal is called the wizard or rat
that's a low pressure control animal
compared to the Shi so this animal has
an upwards entire lifetime and elevated
blood pressure the NIH spent many many
millions of dollars to understand why
this animal has the spontaneous
hypertension I've had that fortune as I
mentioned to study this with our
students in the laboratory and what
became over apparent over time is that
we were looking at the blood pressure as
a symptom in reality this animal was
developing a lot of other complications
it has an unusual endothelial apoptosis
it has insulin resistance just like I
showed you before it has a defective
Meccano transduction mechanism you can
study various cells into your cells
white cells they all have a mission or
transduction mechanism but in these
cells it's defective it's not gone but
it's defective you have an immune
suppression in these the animals can't
sleep very well they have insomnia and
in fact if you study various cells you
find out that's just about every cell
you put your hands on as a defect in
this particular animal so it became
clear to me that this animal isn't is
representative is one example it's a
genetic model of what we call the
metabolic syndrome in other words there
is more than just an elevated blood
glucose level on elevated blood pressure
that is present and there's an
underlying mechanism that could lead to
a complication that extends not just one
particular symptom but many others and
with that we went out with this idea
that there may be uncontrolled proteases
and started to ask the question can we
find proteases in the bloodstream and
the short answer to that yes we found it
when we just take plasma and we measured
with a very broad acting caffeine
substrate the activity we can see that
the SHR has elevated levels compared to
this no intensive control and by the way
both of these strains of animals have an
elevated level compared to the wild type
from which they were originally derived
we spend a good deal of time asking the
question which producers are activated
so we found out that MMP to mmp9 mv7
were activated others were not and it
was always sort of a mild elevation it
wasn't by three orders of magnitude or
so it was a twenty 30 percent elevation
but it was active and that raised and
the question is there possibility that
there is a chronic receptor cleavage
going on so we decided let's look at an
important receptors called the beta-2
adrenergic receptor it sits on the
arteries smooth muscle and it is this
particular guy is responsible for a
vasoconstriction when vasodilation when
you introduce a neurotransmitter like
epinephrine so if that comes in the
bloodstream and hits this adrenergic
receptor it's a very well-studied
receptor by the pharmacologist and you
can see that in fact the blood vessel
should dilate
in the other end in the SHR it doesn't
do so and when we do by the way this is
in a crystallography of the receptor
when we purchased a and found an
antibody against the extrasolar domain
the so-called n-terminus and we labeled
this happens to be the era de the
outside the label gives you the dark
brown color that you see here so the
dark brown color indicates to us that on
the wist on the weekly red there is some
labeling present when we use the
identical method this is all based on a
very careful standardization of
procedures and we labeled in SH our
endeth es el this is the labeling we
found we measured this out with
surprising measurement techniques
telling us that this particular receptor
is no longer present in its intact form
to the same degree as it is in animals
with control blood pressure when we used
an antibody against the c-terminus of
the beta-2 adrenergic receptor we don't
see this phenomenon the inside of the sh
r is labeled as well as the outside and
that tells us that in fact something on
the outside here where our antibody
binds is some is destroyed in the sh r
and to make a long story short we became
interested to look at other receptors in
the same animal this is a labeling of
the insulin receptor so here on these
endothelial cell there's a magnified
view of a view of an arteriole there you
see this little dark line this very thin
line and it is absent in the sh r to a
large degree it's a little bit present
but much less than in the wiki when we
treated these animals with a MMP
inhibitor I remember I showed you this
elevation of the mfp inhibitor and we
used over the years actually multiple
MMP inhibitors this is a treatment that
you need to administer over a couple of
weeks
and then you start to see that in fact
this incent receptor labeling I show you
right here it comes back and the animal
restores that very significantly
question is does this make a difference
for clinical parameters in these animals
so here's the mean arterial blood
pressure this is elevated in the SHR
it's about a hundred and seventy four
millimeter mercury when we treat this
this is one of the treatments group we
used a chemical called doxycycline
that's in at low concentration and MP
inhibitor at high concentrations in
antibiotic and we find out that it's
blood pressure comes pretty much down to
the value of the control animal but even
in the low pressure control we find a
reduction of the blood pressure on that
for the same treatment we now look for
the blood glucose level I mentioned to
you this animal has insulin resistance
so it has a slightly it's not a dramatic
elevation but a slight elevation of the
in blood glucose level this is like I
stated hemoglobin value of five point
seven percent when we treat the animal
the same treatment as up here we bring
this elevated glucose level down to
controls so this was the first direct
evidence that in fact a single treatment
that gets at the root cause of the
problem in these animals naming the
cleavage of receptors is addressing both
aspects well once this idea was born we
immediately became interested in other
types of receptors so let me show you
one or two other examples the SHR it's
very well known for a phenomenon called
capillary refraction this was originally
discovered by some clinicians and they
pointed to the fact that in various
places where you can see human
capillaries in the eye or in the skin
the patient's was elevated blood
pressure had a very poor capillary
network it's rarefied and our SHR has
the same situation this is a magnified
view
it's just a flimsy small capillary
network and compared to the wiki when we
treat this animal this is the same
treatment I just showed you with
doxycycline for a couple of weeks then
in that particular case that capillary
network starts to regrow again by the
way doesn't quite regrow to the same
degree as in the wiki so there are still
some differences but nevertheless it's a
dramatic growth compared to the
untreated animals so this capillary rare
refraction is due to the cleavage of the
vascular endothelial growth factor
receptor
if you treat an animal against you be
Jeff R - it's called
you can achieve in fact the same you can
achieve the same reduction of
capillaries in the tumor field this is
used as a treatment to eliminate so our
concept that I showed you earlier for
the insulin receptor if you look for the
beta adrenergic receptor which is
responsible for arterial baser dilation
and reduction of blood pressure or you
look at the vascular industry of growth
factor 2 it needs to be applied now for
all of three of them and the key culprit
here for a dysfunction of these
receptors is that you have this
extracellular community of proteases
that are clipping these receptors
destroying them and as a result they are
normal function like laser dilation
normal glucose transport or endothelial
survival is interrupted and you get
these clinical signs
so this evidence became in strengthened
our argument that in fact the escape of
digestive enzymes and the generation of
secondary proteases can lead to
widespread organ dysfunctions and we
have studied this in the meantime for
many other receptors and we find the
same circumstance they are being clipped
by digestive enzymes or
their times and they are responsible
therefore a lot of the cell dysfunctions
we should treat these animals with one
single protease inhibitor you could
actually interfere with all of these
what's called comorbidities one of the
question that arises is would this ever
apply to humans well just very recently
and this is still impressed should be
coming out very shortly we asked the
question is there ever a possibility
that digestive enzymes can appear in the
bloodstream of humans so we decided
together with some graduate students to
use a newly developed technique by
Professor Mike Heller that allows us to
measure MMP to activity elastase
activity trypsin activity in addition to
blood glucose level in an individual
that just had a meal so these volunteers
ate a meal sometimes in the morning and
it was a meal that contained besides a
hamburger hot chocolate orange juice and
some donut so it's not a particularly
healthy meal that they ate but we were
curious if we were to follow them over a
period of time and we decided up to five
hours what would their blood glucose
their Proteus activity looks like and
this was done with a new technique that
measured the blood glucose activity Adi
excuse me and the Proteus activity in
much greater with much greater accuracy
than traditional methods and the method
is described and in the literature and
we have applied it to a variety of
different proteases at this stage what
we see there is really interesting this
is the light blue curve is when the
volunteered didn't eat anything this
dark blue curve shows you almost a 50 60
percent increase in Proteus active
just right after the meal this is the
meal takes about 10-12 minutes to finish
and within the next half hour do we see
this elevated proteins activity so just
eating a normal high fat diet meal is
enough according to this data to
increase your protease activity doesn't
make a difference which one you choose
it then quickly returns down again
fluctuates we don't understand why it
fluctuates but it does it's also goes
hand-in-hand with an elevated blood
glucose level when you do the same study
with volunteers who are pre-diabetic or
fully diabetic you see that in a similar
phenomenon but all the curves are much
more elevated and it takes longer
periods of time for them to come back
down again so this is an indication that
there is and this is really surprising
as we go through life by the way these
are young college students here even in
those individuals it is possible that we
find digestive enzymes in their
bloodstream during a normal day this
process you may argue well you discover
that because you used a substrate to see
so and we quickly said well other than
cleavage of a substrate why don't we
look at something much more interesting
so a gustar more destino who did these
studies decided I'm gonna take some
blood samples blood cells of myself so
we're looking at Augusta's white blood
cells over the course of this experiment
and what she did is this took the plasma
from the volunteers or the plasma from
the patients and applied it to her own
cells and then labeled her cells she
applied it typically for about two hours
and then she labelled just like we have
showed you previously she showed the
insulin receptor labeling so it took an
antibody against the extra several
domain of the insulin receptor and then
used immunohistochemistry so and
Instant receptor is what you see in this
particular cell here if you do this to
it cell after such a meal after about 45
minutes do we see that almost no
labeling exists anymore she did only
hundreds of cells and these are some
measurements so she's able to show while
the blood glucose level is just
elevation it's starting to progress to
fall down she sees that there is a large
cleavage of digestive enzymes they buy
digestive enzymes of the insulin
receptor so what we saw in animals
suddenly we see also in humans she did
this this is a control experiment so
these individuals did not in anything we
don't see the cleavage of the receptors
the label density is pretty much the
same throughout the course of this
experiment when we do this with pre
diabetic or diabetic we see a dramatic
cleavage of the insulin receptor
these are her cells but exposed to the
plasma of these patients and there is a
dramatic drop-off so this is the first
indication that in fact this phenomenal
receptor cleavage also occurs in humans
in fact in young college children
college students and this is a process
that needs much more investigation and
is potentially an explanation for the
insulin resistance that can develop
under these circumstances
so what I told you today is this in a
long-winded fashion that besides injury
mechanism that can lead to inflammation
like infection trauma and so on there is
an additional mechanism that's present
and that's order digestion and it's
merely an escape of digestive enzymes
out of the intestine the normal enzymes
that are there to digest our food will
actually digest our own tissue so I'm at
this particular point at the end of this
story
there are many ramifications of that I
thank you all and I will always end up
to wishing my audience a good life and
something that they probably never
thought of Namie I wish them a very slow
or the digestion so we will have to see
where the story goes but that's the end
of mine for today thank you so much dr.
Mitchell Bain
so if you can should close off this
window no no no no you need to just do
the yeah you need to just unshare it
yeah here we go so it was very
interesting so I never heard of this but
it really like asked so many questions
like I'm thinking about so many
questions right now basically in terms
of various diseases and all those things
we can discuss eventually maybe just
couple of questions because we really
went through in detail of all the things
so like you had used MMP for some of the
diseases there like to stop the
digestive enzyme cleavage so is it a
universal or like it may be different
for different diseases or like you have
some ways to figure out a what is good
for this what is good for that right
that's a wonderful question we will the
short answer is we don't know I think we
have techniques today by which for
different diseases we can find out what
are the protease is actually that are
active that are present that are active
and what are they doing I think that
will open up a very direct line of
research for example in the diabetic
patients that tells us okay they have
certain trips and contracts and whatever
the case may be that are under outside
of control and we can find out
and find the most optimal way to inhibit
this this is at the heart of the story
my mind it simplifies the thinking about
many diseases a great deal you notice
that I never spoke about gene expression
because all of these events are
happening and are initiated by extra
subtle of proteases they are the culprit
and my feeling is rather than thinking
about what genes are expressed or how
can i connect a correct a signaling
pathway my thinking as an engineer is
very simple if there are extra seller
proteases that cause this type of
cellular dysfunction the first thing I
want to do when I think about a
intervention for patients how do I stop
these proteases so we think a lot in the
laboratory about these questions and
we're developing techniques that allows
us in specific disease situations to go
directly at these sometimes you are
lucky that you are able to tech these in
plasma and sometimes it's so that the
digestive enzymes I showed you examples
of that actually sitting in the tissue
so you venous blood samples may not tell
you the full story okay and this is kind
of getting into really personalized
medicine kind of thing like okay you
take everybody's like patients like for
particular person it may be little
different than the other proteins which
are getting digested more depending on
their situation so you can basically
target Q particular dose of more of this
inhibitor than the other so like since
you have this company so I was just
wondering are you planning on doing any
diagnostic it's kind of like tools to do
this right Mike Heller Auguste immodesty
no who have worked extensively on this
particular one are the ones who actually
would like to start a company yes
and Mike's idea is this that he would
like to have a manifold so that with a
single finger prick
we will be able to determine in a
particular individual at any instant of
time which produce is are actually
present and then we develop inhibitors
that this particular individual can take
to reduce this activity that'll be
really really interesting so yeah it
brings in together diagnostic place like
the other company where you are trying
to cure the diseases so it's a really
nice work really I appreciate your
contribution to this field for last few
decades basically and reaching to the
point where really you can look into the
humans right now to solve some of the
problems and your example was really
fitting to the real what is happening
these days like where you have don't
have any dissolution to like for example
the sepsis and all so this tool this way
of thinking might be helping them to the
doctors to have something to treat the
patients thank you very much I will be
sharing this with everybody on my
LinkedIn Facebook and you'd be able to
get some response from the people I will
give you if it is okay I can give you
our email address right please do so
thank you unity and I look forward to
the discussion sure certainly thank you
so much we'll get up from this right now